welcome back to the Fox News Channel now
we do have a big announcement starting
Monday September the 25th we're gonna be
moving to 9 p.m. Eastern back where we
started and we're very happy about it
now by the way all my career I've
started out behind the eight ball a
month August for example we were number
two in cable because for some bizarre
reason conspiracy theory TV is working
right now but well with your help and if
you help us spread the word give us a
little time
we're planning on being number one with
your help we also really want to
congratulate a good friend of this
program laura ingraham she's gonna be
taking over the 10:00 p.m. slot at the
end of October and as I wrote on Twitter
earlier today you know when you really
think about I never expected that I
would be the bridge between two
generations of the Fox News Channel this
is the next generation and now we've had
some changes obviously Greta and Bill
and Megan have all left I'm glad to be
back in my own time slot it all starts
next Monday and we're very proud of
Tucker marther and of course now Laura
will see Monday Monday night at 9:00
o'clock anyway will always be fair and
balanced